Carbon dioxide gets the headlines
But cutting methane thirty percent by 2030 could
avoid about zero point three degrees of warming
by 2040
Phasing down HFC refrigerants could avoid up to
another zero point five degrees by 2100
That is huge near-term leverage
Here is the twist both targets depend on
materials we do not have yet
We need catalysts that convert stranded methane without
burning the product and refrigerants that are efficient
safe and low-warming all at once
Fast atomistic AI should help search the options
Except its biggest errors happen exactly where these
materials work surfaces transition states radical fragments and
phase boundaries
In those under-coordinated environments universal models can soften
the energy landscape by fifteen to sixty percent
and rank the wrong candidate first
Methane's carbon-hydrogen bond is brutally strong
A catalyst active enough to crack it often
holds the methanol product too tightly and over-oxidizes
it into carbon dioxide
Corrected barriers can expose rare sites that break
this trap and open lower-temperature methanol or cleaner
hydrogen routes
Refrigerants face a different-looking version of the same
problem
Millions of molecules must be screened for vapor
pressure efficiency flammability toxicity and atmospheric lifetime
The safety-critical steps involve radicals and breaking bonds
the same low-coordination physics that raw models misread
Lupine measures the error versus atomic coordination anchors
a correction field and applies it at runtime
without retraining the base model
Then machine-checked proofs mark which predictions stay inside
the measured domain
Across thirty-six blind model-and-material combinations corrected predictions reached
a correlation of zero point nine zero six
with zero adjustable parameters
Methane catalysts and next-generation cooling are not separate
discovery stories
They share one hidden error geometry and one
chance to turn fast screening into evidence we
can actually trust before the policy clock runs
out